ugh don't tell me you broke another
light bulb
nope i'm just putting in an energy
efficient led
but wait aren't those more expensive yes
but going green can save you money
wait so it costs more and saves you
money yep
[Music]
going green we've all heard about it but
what does it
actually mean simply put it's protecting
the environment from harm
and conserving natural resources these
days there are lots of ways to do it you
can
bike instead of drive eat organic switch
to solar energy and so on
but this isn't new in fact saving energy
has been around for thousands of years
ancient egyptians used to take old
letters and use them for mummy wrappings
to save on papyri
british activists during the industrial
revolution successfully protested the
construction of railways that would have
ruined the land
there are many examples throughout
history of people protecting the
environment
whether they realized it or not but it
wasn't until 1962 that the environmental
movement
really took off with the release of
rachel carson's
silent spring this book informed the
world about pesticides that could cause
cancer and threaten wildlife
this led to the formation of the
environmental protection agency
and helped inspire the very first earth
day where 20
million people across america protested
environmental destruction
since the 1970s awareness of
environmental issues has grown
along with information and resources
helping people go green
thankfully some ways you can reduce
energy cost nothing at all
like recycling or turning off the lights
when you're not using them
but you may have also noticed that many
products and solutions that help us go
green
cost more money than their less
environmentally friendly competitors
what's up with that well sometimes the
product
itself costs more to make that's the
case with organic food which reduces
pollution
but also requires more labor to produce
but that's not always the case with
green products
some charge more because well they can
eco-friendly is unfortunately sometimes
used as a marketing strategy to appeal
to wealthier shoppers
but even with this increased cost
upfront going green can still save you
money in the long run
how much exactly i think it's time to
run the numbers
this is sam she's not the most
environmentally conscious person
in fact the thought of saving energy
never even crosses her mind
but one day sam comes across a ted talk
that gets her really fired up to save
the planet
how much money will she save let's look
at some examples
and heads up there's a lot of numbers
this time so
math nerds you're welcome okay so
currently sam uses 75 watt incandescent
light bulbs for 5 hours a day
she has 40 of them in her home and they
cost a dollar each
if she switches all 40 of these bulbs to
11 watt
leds which cost five dollars each she
has to pay
160 dollars more up front but because
leds use less energy
she'll save about six hundred dollars a
year
that comes out to around fifty dollars a
month so in just over
three months she'll make back the
initial 160 dollars she lost
pretty sweet deal now let's see how much
sam will save by switching
shower heads currently she uses one that
pumps out
two and a half gallons of water per
minute if she buys a low flow shower
head
it only use a gallon and a half per
minute let's say
she takes seven minute showers for 25
days out of the month
and uses an electric water heater with
her previous
shower head that comes out to 438
gallons of water
compared to 263 with her new one pretty
impressive water savings
so it must save a lot of money too right
not exactly this upgrade would only save
her two dollars a month
which isn't a lot but she could put
those savings towards a good cause like
i don't know supporting two cents on
patreon now babe
sorry okay so what if sam switches to an
electric car
i mean general motors just announced
they're switching all their cars to
electric by 2035
so why not sam after all she doesn't
drive the best car for the planet
a 2010 honda accord so if she drives the
average number of miles paying two
dollars and fifty cents a gallon
she'll be looking at over thirteen
hundred dollars a year in gas
alone but if she buys a 2021 nissan leaf
electric car
she'll pay just over 500 a year to
charge it
that's over 800 a year in savings and
while some electric cars cost a
fortune and can be more in insurance a
new nissan leaf
is only around 31 000 and offers
insurance rates that are comparable to
many gas powered cars
sam could also get the federal tax
incentive knocking down the price even
further
plus electric vehicles cost thousands
less in maintenance and repairs over
their lifetime
so she could potentially save around 300
a year on these costs alone if sam's not
ready to ditch her honda though she
could still save money by
biking to work instead of driving and
she'll get in her daily exercise too
so let's assume sam is closer to work
than the average american and it's
10 miles each way that's 100 miles a
week or 400 miles a month she's not
driving in her car
after factoring in operating costs and
maintenance the bike
costs about six dollars a month to ride
to work compared to around 53
a month if she would have driven that
means sam saves about 47
a month by biking to work which is over
a year so if her bike costs her 500
she'll make that up in savings in just
under a year and she might even get a
lower insurance rate by driving less
some insurance companies offer 20 off or
more once you get below a certain number
of miles
others offer smaller discount or none at
all it depends on company demographics
and in some cases if you're willing to
put a tracker in your car
and if sam really wants to go all out
she could get a
solar panel these generate their own
power from the sun
reducing electricity costs by as much as
a hundred percent
admittedly it's a bit pricey for a five
kilowatt system it could cost her twenty
thousand dollars
but she should be able to get a 22
federal tax incentive
knocking off nearly 4 500. on top of
that
she might qualify for local rebates and
incentives so now
let's say we're looking at 12 000 if the
solar panel saves her 100
a month on energy this will pay itself
off in 10 years
then she'll have little to no energy
costs for the remaining 15 years of the
system's life
how cool is that so as you can see
sometimes going green will save you a
lot of money
other times not so much and in some
cases you'll
save nothing at all like if you recycle
or eat organic food
so why do it when it's not financially
beneficial to you
because the truth is the environmental
situation is in critical
condition climate change is causing
extreme
weather events like the snowpocalypse we
endured here in texas a couple months
ago
which could end up having a 200 billion
dollar economic impact
hundreds of thousands of people die from
air pollution every year
and over 500 species of land animals are
on the brink of extinction
because of the human destruction of
nature these
issues affect all of us and while it's
great that in so many cases you'll end
up paying less by going green
that's not the only reason to make the
change doing our part to fight climate
change and protect
the planet is worth doing regardless of
the personal savings
and that's our two cents our pbs friends
across youtube are celebrating earth day
follow me over to weathered ontario to
learn more about the rise in floods in
the age of climate change
and what you can do to prepare tell them
two cents
sent you one more thing for those of you
in the u.s you should check out greta
tuneburg
a year to change the world a new
three-hour earth day broadcast event on
your local pbs station
the special is going to premiere on
thursday april 22nd
at 8 7 central and will then repeat
starting
wednesday april 28th at 8 7 central
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
[Music]
you